j'ai une blague de magasin elle a pas
supermarché
concerné par cette blague Delphine
Bernard
et
continue cette blague
attention
j'essaierai de la
il passe la nuit dans l'avion et puis on
a très envie de faire l'amour à son
compagnon on avait déjà parlé ensemble
tout le monde
tout le monde dort
toute la nuit
sur la fenêtre avec Jean-Michel maire
troupeau de je sais pas quoi qui passe
et qu'il qu'il laisse trop de dégâts il
est complètement handicapé il y a plus
rien qui marche et du coup heureusement
il y a un match qui arrive comme ça et
qu'il le répare et
ça se passe bien
alors
une blague familiale familiale
et donc il appelle sa femme et chérie
elle est en train de faire le marché du
côté de la rue on a gagné au loto
elle arrive elle se fait écrabouiller
bonne journée c'est une bonne journée
[Applaudissements]